so faith careless whisper too funky
george michael his music is timeless and
it will live on tomorrow night at the m
resort with george michael reborn and
the man behind it all is robert barco
the world leading george michael
impersonator welcome to the show my
friend thank you for having me you are
spot on thank you very much when did you
discover that you have this talent well
that's a great question i always say
this talent chose me i didn't choose it
you know from the time i was in high
school and george michael began to
emerge on the scene so many uh fellow
classrooms are saying my goodness you
look just like this hot new singer
george michael and then
strikingly crazy i would open my mouth
and sing in drama club and i sounded
like him
when you're performing you're not you're
not lip singing you're actually singing
singing live when you see me live you
get the british accent everything you
know so yeah it's live
i'm sorry if i'm taking it back i really
am just standing here next year i'm like
i am here with the legend his legacy
lives on through you oh thank you what
are your shows like oh my goodness well
they're a high energy i dance my butt
off you're going to see a lot of costume
changes we cover all the hits from wham
all the way through george michael you
know all of his big hits and stuff like
that so yeah it's it's again it's an
exciting show what's the one song you
look forward to performing oh my
goodness it's hard to pick one right and
there's so many
endless
you know music of george michael the
first time i heard him it was like i had
met a long-lost brother it just my heart
had found its musical home and um you
know actually this show you know a fun
little fact about it is um back in 2019
this show caught the eye of the original
bass player for wham and george michael
mr dion estes so he had joined me on
stage for uh several shows back in 2019.
that had to be special yeah yeah it was
great is there a song that the audience
reacts to more when you're up there too
funky that's one of my favorite songs
what's in the show is it it's number two
yes is there one when you're performing
and the crowd's like you know what
it's funny you say that because uh you
know my band and i talk about that i'd
have to say i don't know if i can say it
on the air but it's the i want your oh
yes yeah yeah that one yeah that's a
good one too the place goes in the nuts
you know
i guess it's forbidden fruit you know do
you perform year round uh yes uh-huh
we've been all over the nation yeah so
heading from here to um new york next
week then california and then oh
goodness you'd have to go check out the
website to get the dates now this the
hair and everything this is the regular
look do you walk through the airport
dress like this and how many people come
up to you i don't walk through the
airport dress like this you're not in
full giving when you walk to the airport
i would
this is just how i look this is my
natural hair this is me so yeah i get uh
quite often recognized we gotta wrap it
stand up look at the look at the full
package right here i mean seriously you
have the whole look going here he got
the whole look on i feel like i'm
standing next to george michael thank
you so much robert we really appreciate
having me so george michael reborn
coming to em resort this is tomorrow
night
great show tickets are still available
and they start at 15
so garth brooks shatters attendance
records we look back at the historical
vegas moment in sin city chronicles and
we got the melts for national sandwich
month where you can go bigger and bolder
to celebrate coming up next
you